Hey,
if you're listening to this podcast and you enjoy it and you really like it and
you're thinking to yourself,
I want to support Conan,
I want to help him in his quest to make the greatest podcast that ever was or
ever will be.
Well,
if you want to help,
uh,
you can,
you see we need the help of some great advertisers and in order to find great
advertisers,
we actually need to know a little bit more about you.
Not in a creepy way and a helpful way.
So if you're interested in helping out,
please go to pod survey.com/conan that's pod survey.com/conan.
Take a quick anonymous survey that will help us get to know you a little better.
That way we can show advertisers how great our listeners are and then the whole
thing comes together in a beautiful way.
Plus,
once you've completed the survey,
you can choose to enter for a chance to win a $100 Amazon gift card.
Of course,
terms and conditions apply.
So again,
that's pod survey.com/conan and uh,
thanks very much for even thinking about lending a hand.
Appreciate it.
Hi,
my name is Kristen Bell.
Hmm.
And I feel super charged about being Conan O'brien's friends.
Oops.
Hey there.
Welcome to Conan O'brien needs a friend.
This is the show where I Conan O'Brien,
talk to celebrities and interesting personalities.
I want the hope of maybe finally finding a true friend,
not someone who's on my payroll.
Those tend to be the people I hang out with,
writers,
producers,
people that work for me.
I want a real friend that likes me.
For me,
I'm aided in my quest by my trusty assistant Sono obsession.
Hi.
And my producer Matt Gorley.
Hi there.
Today's guest is Kristen Bell.
She's an amazing talent and an incredible person and thrilled that she's here.
I like being people's friends.
I think that the point of like earth is to be friendly and nice and to share it
with other people because it doesn't work when we're all islands.
I got to tell you,
I was having sort of a down morning and you walked in here and you are just this
burst of energy and goodwill.
Too much.
No,
no,
no.
I would say take it up a little.
Oh,
okay.
I need a stronger dose.
No,
that was very nice and I agree with you.
I think that is a,
yeah,
the the point and one of the reasons as I think you know,
and maybe you understand my plight,
I work pretty hard.
I have a busy life and I don't think people even realize how hard you work and
not in the sense of like we're not coal miners.
It's not like the most physical activity,
but the,
the amount of brain power it takes in the amount of hours.
I know I've seen how you guys work harder than a Columbian.
Very busy.
I don't know.
I'm going to double down on that.
I think my life is more day to day is more dangerous than a coal miner and
toxic,
toxic.
And I think they should pity me and I'm,
maybe I'm going to get mail for this.
Okay.
But I don't think people mail letters anymore,
so I'm going to let that go.
But I,
I do.
It's hard.
It's a,
it's a,
an an,
you don't have a wife.
I have kids.
So what happens is I,
I realize we're,
am I pals that I hang out with my,
where's my Dang,
which would pass or have time for that.
Yeah.
But then I also need people that are willing to do it.
And that's what's beyond it.
That's on you.
What do you mean you got to make yourself available and you got to put out some
sunshine so that people want to do that with you want to hang out with you.
And you mentioned that when you have a party,
everyone's,
you look around and everyone's on your payroll.
I mean,
dare,
I would say those are better friends.
That's true.
I have country is they're on your payroll and also I can control their behavior.
Well,
no,
it's because it's because you have a shared goal.
Oh because I find my marriage works.
My,
when I get along with my kids the best.
When anything is when you have a shared goal with someone,
I mean that's why we,
I mean we developed out of tribes and when you find a tribe with a shared goal,
you tend to bond with them and you tend to react better towards anything they
say and find them less dangerous.
And when you have a shared goal,
like your show,
they want to stay employed.
It's their job.
They don't like work here because they want to lose their job.
It's,
they have an incentive to keep working here,
which means they want to be friendly.
You guys have a shared goal.
It's the production.
They know that you know,
it's not just you,
it's all these people sitting in this room and they,
there's like so many people in this room.
So many of them don't do anything.
Which ones I guess you know who you are.
Dead Weight,
dead weight,
dead weight.
There's a lot of dead weight.
And I say that with love because you need a certain amount of dead weight.
This leads me to my question.
Okay.
For example,
my wife and I have enjoyed the company of you and Dax and you guys are a
fantastic couple and I thought we all got along and I was thinking is it
possible that we could all be real friends?
Is that a possibility?
I think so.
Okay.
You hesitated.
Hesitated
because I want expectations to be accurate and reasonable because the reality is
we also have very busy lifestyles and you have a very busy lifestyle.
So we just to,
you know,
like the Buddhist say like desire and yearning.
It's just like a wasted emotion.
So like saying we owe,
we should strive to get together once a week.
That's never going to happen.
But like once every couple months planning it like a dinner or something or like
a pool party,
that could totally happen.
So we go in and say,
what do we want to commit to?
Cause we like spending social time together and there are shared goal is
friendship,
right?
And then we can definitely do it because you need buddies.
I need some real friends,
you know,
and,
and I'll tell you something else.
Um,
I'm very comfortable,
really comfortable with you and really comfortable with your husband and my wife
likes you guys.
And so it just feels like,
you know what,
people like my wife a lot more than they like me.
Yeah.
My assistant's Sona who's here once said to me,
your wife's,
the only thing I like about
it is it is true.
What an honest friend
David thinking about calling it.
A lot of people have that.
I was at a restaurant last night and I was sitting there alone because I had to
go downtown and do a show and I was putting my notes together.
So I just went to grab a quick bite and I'm name dropping here,
but Reese Witherspoon is that the next booth?
And uh,
she's like Conan,
Conan,
where's your wife?
And I said,
I'm,
I'm just here alone.
I'm working on my setlist for this show I have to do tonight.
And she said,
I love Leisa.
I love your wife.
Anyone.
Yeah.
And I'm thinking,
what about me?
What am I checking?
As they said back in the day.
What about me?
What am I chopped liver right here.
Shut up liver,
whatever,
but you know,
but,
or,
okay,
this is the problem here.
Look,
I'm rolling up my sleeves.
We're about to dig in.
What's that?
What happened was something on your skin.
This Elmers glue.
I think we were making crafts last night or you were sniffing glue.
Is it good?
Can you get,
Oh,
it's
frustrating.
You are wearing the you,
you need to switch classes.
Okay.
The Lens you're looking through.
Oh,
this is a metaphor I thought you meant.
I really do need different ones.
Yeah,
those aren't working.
I'm Reese Witherspoon.
You didn't even recognize me.
I just saw a blonde blob and I didn't know what all understandable,
but Reese Witherspoon would never have crossed to God.
No.
God,
no.
You can't see within that situation how that's a compliment to you because you
pick,
not only did you pick your wife,
but your wife loves you and if your wife is so wonderful,
her number one pick is you.
You can't see that as a compliment.
I'm not sure.
I was number one.
Okay.
She may have suit.
Who knows whatever options were at the time,
but she didn't choose to be with you and all of these other people who gravitate
towards your wife and her loveliness.
Your,
her number one.
That's a compliment to you.
She was a,
it was between me and Ryan Gosling at the time.
Wait,
sorry,
what was that?
Nothing.
I was,
I dunno,
maybe she settled.
I'm sorry.
It's Ryan Gosling.
Here's my theory about why you feel like you don't have friends because I
personally know a lot of people that love you and your time,
your available time in your day is not the reason that you don't have
friendships while it is,
but maybe you don't do enough self care.
What do you do for self care?
What do you do that just for you?
Wow.
That's just for you now.
For the show.
Not for anything.
Like do listen to a podcast like I do,
like I like history.
Okay.
Dax and I have that in common.
Yeah,
like books on tape.
I like listening to long histories.
Uh,
if I go on a vacation with in with my family,
everyone else is reading sort of like a light book and I've got a William
Shirer's rise and fall of the Third Reich,
which is a big black book with a swastika on it.
And I'm reading it in a bathing suit with a rum drink and getting closer to why
you don't have friends.
We're getting closer.
Um,
so okay,
so first of all covered the book kitty stickers or something.
That's number one.
Somebody wants to,
can we swear on this podcast?
Can nobody wants a fucking swastika on their book.
You know what I should've done is put like a sisterhood of the traveling pants
jacket over that book.
People thought it was real sisterhood of the traveling pants,
but I'm really reading about it was such a great fit.
Any more contacts in your phone?
If you sat on the beach reading sisterhood,
people becoming up and dropping their phone number on your lap,
do you even know the plot of that?
Is it is missing their drawers?
I'm assuming their slacks,
they,
there's genes and different girls wear them.
And does anyone understand central here?
The probably pants.
All I know is there's a pair of pants that fits all of them.
Oh.
And shared goal and shared goals.
It's like a community thing.
Something that bonds them together.
Shared goal.
So you,
you,
you don't have time.
So your expectations are all scatty want this.
You don't have time.
So yeah.
So if you want friends,
you've got to make time for your friends,
which means you gotta be like,
what two hours a week can I carve out?
You've got to schedule it.
Just like you schedule this podcast,
you scheduled this with me,
you schedule The bits that you take for your show.
You schedule your show.
What time do we shoe?
When we shoot guys with time,
he,
we shoot for four 30.
Yeah.
You schedule that.
He make a little time for your buddies or some self care.
You go get your nails done,
you take a bath,
you go on a hike.
I actually exercised quite a bit.
But,
uh,
I never sit in a bath because I don't have the patience to just sit and they
probably don't fit well in the tub too.
I don't,
yeah,
I seek dangle off the end.
Basically.
It's just my torso in the bath.
Nope.
You're like,
yeah,
you're sitting in a sauce pan.
So like maybe like a steam room or a sauna or get a massage or just go on a walk
by myself.
Yeah.
This is what I'm saying.
You don't,
you,
you're maybe,
oh my God.
You guys.
Maybe the Pete,
the other people aren't the answer.
Maybe your,
the answer.
Maybe you need to become friends with yourself.
You need to play dramatic music here or like music.
Like a light.
Just enlightenment.
Yeah.
If we can afford it.
Well,
I'm noticing you take really good care of yourself.
You have seven different drinks right here.
Now there's a green drink.
I don't know what that is.
Water h two o that's water.
But this looks like you took a rain forest and put it in a blender.
Yeah.
This is macho.
This is much it.
And then I got a protein shake in there and a green tea in there because I like
I,
I hydrate a lot and I need to have different types of hydration's in order to
feel safe.
It's like,
I don't know,
I always have a big bag like that and it's always filled with just the bottle
after bottle of different liquids.
And sometimes I'm got a coffee in there and mostly Amartya I just,
I need a lot of different drinks and then I do waters cause I don't like to come
and waste the plastic water bottle.
So.
So you're going to the restroom every five minutes?
No,
weirdly not.
I like,
I like a camel.
I don't know.
This is interesting.
So what I've picked up so far,
and I'm not saying that you're wrong,
is that I need to drink a lot of liquids.
I need to realize that I'm the problem and I need to walk by myself.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's my bag and get a longer tub.
Yeah,
that's,
you can find them.
But those long tubs are probably so expensive.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's talk about this cause that's interesting.
You are a frugal woman and I say that as a compliment.
They time you are a big time for a woman.
Is that come from just the way you were raised?
I mean you use,
you use coupons,
you uh,
but like why not use a coupon?
Exactly,
yes.
The way I was raised.
I mean I um,
I grew up in Detroit.
My husband and I are both like this,
but I think that's because of where we grew up.
There was,
you know,
a bit of a scarcity factors.
So out here I also work really hard for money also like to support things that I
believe in like charities and philanthropy endeavors.
And so I like to have money.
I prefer to have money to do that kind of stuff and then cut corners with
myself,
not with myself.
It's not like I'm like,
you know,
wearing holes in my shoes.
But um,
I have realized that spending like a ton of money on myself and not being
responsible doesn't make me any happier.
Yes.
It actually makes me happier to like sort of penny pinch and then be like,
oh,
I can donate to this when I want to.
And it's incredibly a,
you have a great moral compass.
You really do.
You is,
how much of that do you credit to Catholicism growing up Catholic?
Oh,
no,
no.
I mean,
no,
because I definitely,
like I went to Catholic school and grew up Catholic,
but I am not Catholic.
I am sort of have no religion.
I'm a humanist.
And I think,
I mean,
I suppose being in a community growing up,
which I think sometimes churches do well and there,
you know,
I take a lot of issue with a lot of other things they do.
But I think um,
community building does make you realize how to walk in someone else's shoes,
how to recognize empathy and where it exists and sort of,
yeah,
figuring out that you're not alone.
I think that's really important.
But I think that can be done within a church or within a theater group or within
a baseball team or within your family if you have a lot of siblings or even if
you have none,
you know,
it's not,
church isn't the only place growing up.
I grew up in a very catholic,
I don't really think my morality came from the Catholic Church.
I really do think so much of it is monkey see monkey do.
Oh,
all of it is.
And I,
with my,
you know,
if my son ever is like somewhat rude to my wife or something else,
say,
do you ever see us talk to each other that and do we ever talk to you that way?
And I can see him realize,
oh no,
I've never,
I don't witness that day to day it's,
he can't argue with that.
Whereas if he saw us constantly don't cough,
we cannot,
it's one of my drinks.
If you didn't get enough of your 30 liters of algae,
um,
we did the same thing and in fact act.
So it says when the girls are mean to me,
cause I'm more of a pushover,
he'll go,
don't you dare talk to my wife that way.
Like he'll use it as a defense of me and Renee Brown,
who's one of my favorite writers,
says,
you cannot give your children anything you do not have.
So like I can't give my children the ability to have a good positive body image
unless I have a good positive body image.
So it's worth recognizing that if you want your children to grow up happy and
well rounded and be surrounded by friends,
you have to show them that in your existence and self care and all those things.
Got to give it to them.
You got to show it to the little ones because they don't listen to Jack Shit
that you say.
They just ignore it.
But when they see you talk to people or they see you after they see you say,
I need 20 minutes to go sit by myself and read,
or I need to meditate,
or I'm going to take a walk around the block,
or I'm going to exercise for my body,
or I'm going to take a nap,
or I'm gonna call my mom.
They witnessed those things.
That's the big rule I've always had with my kids is you a lot of choices about
what you're going to do with your life,
but you're going to be nice.
Like that is going to be polite and you're going to be nice.
That's the thing that I'm always on them for.
My wife is too,
you know when we're in a,
in a restaurant and the waiter comes,
if,
if they're not making eye contact and saying hello,
thank you,
could I please have?
I'm all over him being nice to everybody,
be nice to people,
but in a,
in a genuine way.
But just you have to,
you know,
and how old are your kids?
They're in their late fifties.
Okay.
So they probably understand this a little bit more.
But Mike mine are at like concept level.
They don't listen to what we say and they don't really understand why is,
but my husband is so good at giving everyone context and I've learned from him
that like when they're ordering as opposed to going like look at her,
look at her,
cause all they're like,
why?
So My I,
Oregon has to look at her Oregon while I,
what does that have to do with me choosing a cheeseburger?
But I say like when they leave or before they come up,
I'll say,
oh look at the waiter.
Um,
it looks like maybe he's been working here for all day today and maybe he's got
a family at home.
Do you think he has kids?
He might,
he might wish this day went by quicker so he could see his kids.
He looks like he's a really hard worker because I see all those plates in his
hand.
He's doing a really great job.
So I identify the person that they should be kind to as another valuable human
being.
Right.
So that they hopefully take the initiative to then recognize him in an sort of
empathic way that,
oh,
I should be nice to him.
I want to say this.
I want to say that in this town,
in Los Angeles,
in this business,
I think what you're talking about is not that common unfortunately.
And that's because people don't take the time to recognize that everyone else is
also a human being that has a favorite color and a favorite ice cream and a mom
that annoys them.
And uh,
you know,
someone that they're dating and a favorite pair of shoes.
Everybody has those favorite things.
It's not just you.
But I think one of the,
one of the biggest problems in Los Angeles is,
and I've noticed this,
there are other areas where you're forced to constantly be in contact and it's a
good thing,
but whether you like it or not,
you have to be in contact with people that have more than you,
less than you.
And here in Los Angeles you can carve out a life.
And I think increasingly this is what's happening in this country because of
technology.
People can carve out a life where they get up in the morning,
they get in their car,
they go exactly to their place and when they're in their car,
they only listen to exactly the kind of music and news that they want to hear.
They don't have to interact with anybody else.
And then they get to the place where they do the specific thing.
They ordered,
the exact things they want on Amazon.
They watched the exact shows that give them pleasure and they're never exposed
to anything like a devil's advocate point of view or a person that thinks
differently or just something.
Well look,
look,
that's,
it's normal for us as monkeys to want to do that.
That's tribal.
You want to find sameness always.
But you believe in evolution.
I do.
Oh,
I'm so sorry.
You should go.
I'll take my drinks for having me.
I believe that we,
a man was created in 1922
deal.
Tell me more.
And all the animals.
It was in 1922 and then we have implanted memories.
This makes so much more sense than what I was looking at,
like archeological records.
And No,
no,
no.
Don't do that.
That's a mistake that was all put there to trick us.
That makes sense.
Noah's Ark,
and this is actually a true fact.
A Noah's Ark was built in 1919 so by Russell Crowe.
Exactly.
A guy who I don't think he and I are becoming friends anytime soon.
We're gonna have to take a quick break.
I don't know much about podcasts,
but I think during this break I'm going to make millions of dollars.
Congratulations.
Let's do this.
Take a break.
Oh,
now it's time for a segment called Conan O'Brien pays off the mortgage on his
beach house.
It took out a big mortgage beach house.
Then I just on an impulse,
I built a big deck.
Turns out it's not legal.
I didn't get clearance.
You just built it without asking anyone.
If it was okay to belt.
I built it myself and I'm not even a good builder.
Yeah,
that was stupid to really,
back then,
no architectural drawings built it myself.
Most of it fell down on its own,
but then it turned out I had to remove the rest because it was illegal.
So anyway,
Hey,
all this fall I've been checking something off my bucket list for years and
years and years.
It's been my dream to go out on tour,
hit the road with,
so my favorite comics and I've been doing that.
In fact right now I'm recording this in my hotel room in Austin,
Texas cause we got a show here tonight.
It's a nice hotel room than mine.
It's much nicer than yours.
I put you in the same room as the giant ice machine and the extra towels it and
it's a fun show.
Sona,
you've seen many of them.
Yes.
It's a really fun show.
All the comics are amazing.
Absolutely.
And how am I good?
Oh Geez.
Anyway,
it's been a blast.
It's a lot of fun.
And uh,
we are headed soon to Chicago,
Minneapolis and in Milwaukee.
So if you're in Chicago,
Minneapolis or Milwaukee and you want to come see the show,
I guarantee you'll have a good time.
Grab tickets@teencoco.com slash tour and so now I will get you a better room.
Do you have a window in your room?
No,
I did ask them not to give you a window.
I don't think it's an actual room.
I sleep on the floor.
Yeah,
it's a storage space.
This may surprise some people,
but I am not just a podcaster.
I also dabble in a little something called television.
Oh yeah.
For a little while.
Just 25 years.
Sorry to come across angry.
Anyway,
I have this TV show that I've been taking all over the world.
Uh,
and I love doing this.
I've gone to places like Cuba,
Armenia.
We went to Armenia.
SONA.
That was fun.
Yeah,
we went to Haiti.
We went to South Korea.
So many different countries.
I love these episodes.
Well,
I just want to tell you that my new episode of Conan Without Borders is about to
come out.
And in this one I traveled to Japan.
Sona,
you've seen the Japan show.
It's absolutely hilarious.
Yeah,
it's really funny.
It's really funny.
There's a lot of fun surprises in it.
Very proud of this episode.
You visited a place called Conan town.
Yes.
In Japan.
I have a lot of adventures.
There's a few,
there's a little guest appearance there.
It's really fun.
Yeah.
And so I'm hoping people will check it out.
Kona Without Borders.
Japan air is November 28th on TBS and make sure to visit team coco.com/japan to
look at all kinds of behind the scenes stuff,
extras,
live streams and more.
Thank you.
I'm new to this podcast thing.
How long have you been doing this?
Uh,
I think 48 hours.
No,
48 hours straight.
I,
I'm on a lithium drift.
Um,
uh,
I've been doing this,
this is pretty new I have to say.
And I,
there's a bunch of things I really like about it.
And actually today when I was driving in and I was excited to come in and talk
to you,
I'm driving to work and I started to think to myself,
oh,
I need to get there a little early to leave time for makeup.
And then I realize,
no,
you get to just look at my,
what's it meant rapidly aging folks.
I'll be honest,
Irish men after 50,
we're just like,
I mean,
look,
I'm right around the corner that Pale skin and my God,
we had some spice in us because it's,
we're doomed.
You're going to be beautiful forever.
You are.
I,
there's a gene inside may,
a certain kind of Irish male where he looks okay for a while and then around 50,
the gene triggers and our heads become sort of a bloated orange,
uh,
massive cauliflower and uh,
and,
and our bodies fall apart and that's happening.
That's happening to me and I'm fighting it.
I'm going to do whatever I can.
I'm going to get radical surgery.
Just pull it,
tape it.
Lucille Ball.
Did you know what Lucille Ball did?
She used to use tape and she would take,
everyone still does that.
Oh,
she use tape and then she put the big orange wig on top of it.
There's a lot of people who sell men and women who take like the sides of their
cheeks or their forehead.
And especially even back here and when I'm doing for the viewer is holding my
mandible and pulling it back towards the lobes of my ears.
And then they take it back there.
But you got to hide the tape.
Yeah.
But you can hide that with like a little like teasing of the hair.
Let's see.
That's easier for women.
Blue Painter's tape.
They're using clear tape.
Oh,
I was imagining painters.
No,
no,
no.
I'm just imagining that I should have specified.
I was imagining Dora the explorer bandaids that are big and colorful.
You know what I think I'm going to do and I'm not,
I'm not,
I don't want to get any kind of surgery.
And I love working and I love,
uh,
being on television.
I love the whole thing,
but I don't want to get any kind of surgery to fix my face.
So what I'm going to do now that I'm,
uh,
you know,
slowly aging is a use tape.
I'm going to use tape,
but I'm going to switch to a wig because the wig,
we'll hide the tape.
Don't you see if it's a clear,
it's hay and it'll be like what Lucille ball did.
You'll never,
ever,
not in this town or any other town,
get awake as good as that hair.
I've got great hair.
You've got gray hair.
Great,
great.
Have game show host hair.
You know,
I get excited when I see it.
I'm like,
here's Conan.
That's right.
The hair and makeup is very annoying and podcasts don't require anything of you.
My husband loves doing his podcast because he,
he just has to sit there.
I couldn't believe it doesn't have to do hair and makeup,
laziest job in the world,
and here's the way,
so built for it.
He loves asking intimate questions to strangers.
Yeah.
He's always,
the person that has asked gets way too intimate way too quick,
and that's literally no,
his job.
I'm the podcast.
I was shocked.
I did his podcast.
I loved it.
He's terrific.
Terrific interviewer.
But I was really,
he just sits in this big,
it's a lazy boy,
big lazy boy,
and he's got a microphone near his face,
but his posture isn't good.
He's,
he's,
he's collapsed in the lazy boy.
Like he's just sending the maximum comfort.
He's at maximum you would you sit in it?
He probably didn't let him know.
He didn't let me sit in it,
the most comfortable chair on the planet.
And look,
it's slightly bulky for my opinion.
I bought it for him cause I put it in his office when he was working here at
Warner brothers.
Did you get it for a good rate?
I paid a premium.
I paid a premium for that chair.
It's a very good chair,
but it's a lazy boy chair and it kicks back and it's the most comfortable thing
I've ever sat it.
And so I bought,
do you know about this whole this,
we made this a pretty public saga at the time,
but a couple of years ago I bought it for his office and then his office here at
Warner Brothers closed because the project ended.
He brought it home,
it put it in my living room while I was like,
excuse me,
which would have been fine to discuss except he put it directly in front of the
couch facing the television.
Not Angled towards like a nice funkshway.
Literally,
literally,
let me describe this.
So the couch is up against the wall and let's say that's the TV.
So the couch of faces,
the television,
he put it in the middle,
like in front of the coffee table facing the television.
I was like,
what?
What are you doing this that?
That's an aggressive literally and I've,
I have posted photos of me watching a movie looking at the back of his head.
I said,
this is so unacceptable.
And I guess what?
I couldn't lift the chair so I couldn't move it.
It's a big chance,
so heavy and it's so well made and it's so comfortable.
So I'm mad at it,
but I also love it.
So when he got the podcast and he started doing it in the attic,
he moved the chair up to the attic.
Yeah.
The whole time I was talking to him,
I was just thinking,
he is so comfortable and I'm not as the chair I was sitting in his mind,
the little,
it's something that you,
it's the chair a nurse makes you sit in a,
you know,
an iron share.
While you,
while she draws blood in a clinic that's not well run,
we've got to do better for our guests.
Because the other thing about that podcast room is it doesn't have a door on the
bathroom,
which he finds notice that totally acceptable.
And I am just apoplectic about,
I can also a window in the bathroom that doesn't have a,
so I urinated after the podcast because I drank a lot of water.
Okay.
Channeling you and then,
and there is no curtain and the,
I don't know how to say this,
but there's,
it's just open to the street,
that window.
And so
and so I was urinating and let's just say everything's out,
you know,
as,
as it has to be what a man urinates and I'm thinking it would be so easy right
now for somebody to get a shot of me with my don Johnson.
Uh,
and just assuming that's what everyone calls there is,
um,
uh,
not an ideal situation,
but he seems to think it's acceptable.
And like we had Katie Kirk in there and I was,
I was like trying to welcome her and be like a host set,
put like little candles in their forum and like try to make it nice and like,
I was like,
Katie,
I'm so sorry that you have to pee.
And she was like,
there's no door on the bathroom.
I'm not going to pee in here.
And I was like,
secretly I was like,
yes,
Katie,
stand up for yourself.
But look,
that's like his kit.
He likes it.
It's makes them laugh that there's no door on the bathroom.
You're a very understanding your,
you love him for who he is.
He's a lovable guy there.
Lots of love.
But,
um,
I love how accepting you are of other people.
I have realistic expectations.
I cannot change anyone else.
It's not my podcast.
I'm allowed to put a lavender scented candle in there,
but I'm,
you know,
it's not my podcast.
He's,
he's allowed to treat his guests how he wants to treat them.
I want to ask you quickly,
and people don't know this about us that much,
but we both have motorcycle licenses.
Ah,
yes,
I know.
Uh,
that was something that I just always wanted to do at some point and I did it a
bunch of years ago and I have all these rules with my bike.
Like I don't,
I ride it when no one else is around.
I'm very,
I think I'm extremely safe.
You know,
this is one of your self care items.
It is a self care item problem at time for that.
The problem is my wife not happy.
Her deal was she said you can buy a motorcycle if it never leaves the living
room.
She really doesn't want me out on a motorcycle.
Are you a good driver or no?
All right.
I'm good.
I mean,
as compared to what I mean,
I'm saying bad driver.
No,
no.
Oh,
very good.
Very good.
I said understand,
follow me here.
Okay.
Now I feel like one of your children,
because I have the say I have the same nerves about my husband riding.
Well,
he's an excellent,
the reason that I have to set up excellent.
Uh,
I mean he's been doing it his whole life.
No.
Am I in his league?
Not even close,
but I dunno,
it's,
it's very hard to describe to people.
It sounds like,
oh,
you're just,
you're having some midlife crisis like,
no,
it really is something.
I was real rode bicycles for a really long time and I always thought this would
be much more fun if there was an engine on this thing.
It feels good to my husband too.
It feels the same way and I don't necessarily have that same feeling,
but I,
and I have that feeling in other areas and I'm able to understand that that is
very important to him.
And then if it's not anything that I'm going to get him to stop doing or what I
want him to stop doing,
if it's something that really makes them feel happy,
would you be willing to talk to my wife about this?
I love your wife.
Of course.
It's up to you.
Everyone lights up when he was a,
you know,
as a compliment.
I will.
I feel bad for Ryan Gosling.
He blew it.
I do want to compliment you.
It is very hard for my entire family to find one show that everybody likes that
matches my,
I'm such a comedy snob and good places.
The best show,
it really is.
It really is.
The writing is brilliant.
Performances are great and I think it's one of the most unique comedies that's
been made.
I mean in the last 10 years I couldn't be happier at that job.
Would you be cool if that was what the afterlife would you be?
Would you accept that version of the afterlife?
Well,
yes and no because the show is about our characters did not get in or are having
trouble getting in.
So I don't know that I look two separate questions.
If Mike Schur ran my afterlife 100% right,
but be entertaining.
Even if you were in hell,
it would be entertained.
Yes.
But there's things that we have,
like things like toilets,
spiders,
and you know,
all these crazy things he's invented in,
in,
in health.
But I think that it should be easier for people to get rewarded for good
behavior.
Being human is very hard.
Maybe that's what we learned today.
I'm a guy that likes to summarize.
Um,
I'm also a guy that likes to wax this chest,
but I don't know why you needed to know that.
I'm,
I'm hard to summarize because I'm a nonlinear thinker and speaker and like
somewhat of a scatter brain.
So like I make a whole bunch of weird points that don't often connect and just
talk and talk.
So it's not found that to be true.
Really?
No,
not at all.
I can tell that you read a lot.
I can tell that you're,
you're always on the hunt for new information,
new information and what's the way to be?
I'm hungry and curious.
You're hungry cause you're only drinking liquids.
All liquid diet.
Really know.
What are you going to have set a Bagel?
You had a Bagel and two eggs this morning and then I had a Bagel.
You put them in a blender first and then everybody does that.
I don't think so.
Oh,
I want to end by saying my goal in the next year is I want to have one dinner
with my wife and I and you and Dax.
I'd like us to fight over the check,
but then I'd like to win and pay for it.
I can be a part of this plan.
This is a reasonable expectation.
This is not an expensive restaurant.
Okay.
I know a place in Santa Monica,
it takes a whole fish,
the whole fish and puts it in a blender and then everyone gets a big beer Stein
and they drink the fish out of the Beer Stein.
Okay.
Take that lender,
drive it from Santa Monica to the east side of Los Angeles.
Okay.
And then we can do it.
You know what I'm going to do,
going to take the bus,
I'm going to take the next step right in front of me.
Yeah.
And I can bring rob blended fish with me.
Can I tell you how excited I am getting for this dinner date?
Because all of the things you're saying,
just the blender and the fish and the bus stop and you're an amazing actor.
You really had me believing that you were excited about this.
Well,
thank you very much.
I know how busy you are,
but uh,
I'm just,
uh,
I adore you.
And,
and your husband and uh,
it was,
uh,
nothing less than an honor to have you come in and chat with me.
Really.
Thanks for having me.
Yeah,
this is really uplifting and when I mean that sincerely,
I really do.
You're in very,
very uplifting person.
Thanks.
And we'll agree that no one has to wear makeup at our dinner party.
How we made up.
Okay.
I'm going to have my face tape and I'll be wearing a very obvious red wig.
Now the Conan's out of the room,
you can speak frankly freely.
What is the likelihood that you think you'd be friends with Conan in the future
or after this?
Um,
it's high and they'd be honest.
Yeah,
it's,
hi.
Can I tell you you're the first really?
Well,
I like a good challenge and Conan is somewhat of a grump and I like to uplift
the grumps shared goals.
Yeah.
Good.
Thank you very much.
Huh?
Okay.
It's time for a segment I invented called true or false with SONA,
most Sassy and he ready to go.
So no,
not really.
You don't like these days?
I hate these.
They're good because they explore the truth of our dynamic.
This one is from today.
Oh,
here we go.
Uh,
you know that I am a hard worker.
I was up pretty late last night,
uh,
doing a,
a live show downtown.
Didn't get a ton of sleep,
try to sleep in a little bit this morning.
Worked out and then I'm rushing to work so that I can get here in time to record
the podcast and I don't want to be late.
I'm a professional and I have our text exchange does.
I'm racing racing to get here.
Hold on.
Don't say anything.
This is the exact exchange right from my phone.
I took a screenshot,
I said,
and I was hoping that you would set this up.
I'd like to Conference Matt G and Adam on the way in.
You wrote back,
okay,
I'm making a Bagel in the kitchen.
True or false.
I think we know it's true because I just read it.
Yeah,
it's true.
It's true.
Okay.
You wrote,
you screenshot it,
you have the evidence.
It's true.
I can't even lie.
And also I would,
how does what?
How does what you say follow what?
I said,
how does that,
so how does that follow in any way?
I said,
well,
I got to set up,
we got to set up this conference call with these two guys for the podcast that's
happening in 20 minutes.
And you said,
okay,
I'm making a Bagel in the kitchen.
We have a little kitchen here at the show.
Here's what I eat.
I remember sending text,
here's where I was at.
You send me that text and I was mid spread on my Bagel.
I was like,
do I abort this mission right now and go back and set up this conference call or
do I finish this,
you know,
take care of my Bagel and then take that with me and then do this conference
call.
And I made the executive decision
that it would have taken two minutes,
but I didn't want you to think that I was ignoring you.
What I should have done was make my Bagel quietly do it,
go back to my desk and just been like,
sure.
Fire away.
I think.
I think it's fair to say that you're too honest with me sometimes.
That's fair to say.
I think it's fair to say that I'll say to you,
uh,
yeah,
things are tight.
I've been working real hard.
The margins are thin.
I'm on the run.
I got to get there.
Uh,
helped me with this thing and you'll say,
I'm making a Bagel and it almost sounds like
a craftier person.
Here's what I am.
And this is a compliment which is all disguised as a slam.
You are without guile.
You are not deceptive.
You don't lie.
No.
One of the most honest people I've ever met to a fault.
Here's what I hate about this segment is I sent that to you and you didn't
respond,
which is never,
it's never good.
You know why?
Cause I knew I had the goods.
You are now reserving just shitting on me for the podcast in a compliment.
It did.
Betty your reserve on it.
Now instead of I am,
I take responsibility every time I do something wrong.
I think there's nothing wrong with letting you know your text has been received.
Here is my status.
Bagel.
Preparation of status.
I am a Bagel prep stage of my day and when that has been completed,
we will address the concerns.
Here's my question.
Are you upset?
Because I didn't drop everything I was doing.
You don't get it.
I'm not upset at all.
No,
I'm not upset.
I wasn't upset.
I wasn't upset for a second.
When you sent that I got that.
I looked at what I said,
we've got to set this thing up.
Time is tight and you wrote back,
I'm making a Bagel and I thought,
this is great.
I have this for the podcast.
This is amazing.
But I just,
I knew I had you and I knew that I was going to be able to use this.
Uh,
you know,
for the amusement of fathers brought joy to a lot of people.
At least,
at least I don't know how podcasts work,
but I'm guessing in the hundreds of millions I,
oh wow.
These are worldwide,
I think.
And I,
this is going to go huge.
I think you enjoy your staff's ineptitude more than anybody else.
I root against my staff really to,
because when my staff fails,
I love making fun of them more than I like things going well at the show.
I would rather any project we're working on,
whether it's the show or the podcast or anything,
I would rather have it not be as good.
But I catch staff members making a mistake and I get to have fun with it.
Yeah.
That is my insanity.
I love it.
I actively root against everyone who works for me.
As your new producer,
do you know how nervous this thing?
Oh,
I can't believe you didn't,
they didn't warn you about me?
No,
not really,
but I got the,
I got it pretty quickly I think.
Yeah.
It's uh,
it looked this morning we were talking on the phone and we were pitching out
some ideas and uh,
if there was one I didn't really love you hung up.
I didn't hang up.
I didn't hang up,
but I can't,
you tell I'm joyous.
I have a lot of energy when I hear something I don't like and I love to go on a
long,
I would say not a cruel but a long riff.
You're pure shot in Freud.
Yeah,
right.
Just exactly.
I just shot him.
Freud is my favorite German sausage.
It's a rooting for,
but it's crazy thing is that I do it with,
everyone here is working to help me and I actually,
I'm in and I really do love the people I work with.
I am being as honest as I can be.
I love the people I work with.
I don't know.
That was a blanket statement.
I love Sona blaze in the room.
Uh,
there's,
well I don't know some of these other guys.
I'm going to be honest with you.
I don't know who you creeping around.
Who are you,
John?
I know John's only been with me for like eight years.
You've gotta be in John,
you've got to be in like 15 years before you in the club.
But the point is,
I really do love the people I work with.
I think I'm a good boss in in a lot of ways,
but the insane thing about me is the joy I take in things going wrong and even
if it hurts the overall,
the overall endeavor,
I don't understand.
Someone helped me.
I don't either.
How many times a day would you say in the time that you've known me?
I've said out loud to a room full of people.
Someone please take me to the hospital.
Oh,
I think you see it every 20 minutes.
Someone please take him to the hospital and,
and,
and because you're all,
you're all making a living off of my sickness.
Well,
how dare you.
What do you,
well,
the pay will listen,
this thing's going to explode.
All right.
And when it does,
you are going to be dressed like a pimp.
You know?
Right now you're in your whatever,
your Los Filez cool hip.
I don't live in Los Felix.
I don't know.
I don't want to know where you live.
You're wearing that shirt.
That's like maybe I'm a prospect or,
but maybe also I,
I worked for podcast,
I mentioned that you have a fob of I think,
who is that?
It's a five.
It's a yes,
it's,
this is,
um,
I love this.
This is,
uh,
I was in Mexico City.
We shot a show there and I wanted to go see the home.
Were Trotsky got an ice pick task?
Yeah.
So I got this when I was there.
There's a gift shop.
You're the pendant broach of Trotsky hanging off your pocket.
Right.
Cause I was there.
I earned it.
It's not something I ordered.
Like you want EPA to try and get points when I'm getting my Mocha Chai Chapo,
this I got,
because I'm the only late night host,
maybe the only entertainer in America who's ever gone to the home.
We're Trotsky was murdered.
And not only that,
I then went to the gift shop and bought this little pendant that has a picture
of Trotsky.
And when my favorite thing is that I've had more than one person walk up and go
point to it and go,
oh,
I love Bhorat too.
They think it's a bore at Penn.
I thought it was a bit from like a prop from UB segment on your show,
or you played your own ancestors or something.
No,
no,
no.
That's Trotsky.
Trotsky.
Uh,
for those of you listening who don't know will quickly become a history podcast.
Trotsky,
uh,
was one of the founders of the revolution,
the Russian revolution,
uh,
with Lennon and s people like stolen.
And then of course when Stalin took power,
Trotsky was out.
So Trotsky had to run away and he ran away and he ran all the way to Mexico City
and he thought he was safe,
but Stalin doesn't give up on a grudge.
So we sent a guy with an ice pick.
It's very Russian.
Yeah.
Russian or your husband is part Russian?
No,
no,
he's Armenian.
He grew up in the Soviet Union.
Right.
So he speaks Russian.
Yeah.
But he also has a certain Russian sensibility because he grew up in the Russian
Soviet system.
That's true.
That's all I meant by that.
Yeah,
no,
that's very true.
Here's the interesting thing.
You like going places where people died.
Yeah.
I,
I love it.
When you travel,
you're like,
that's where so and so,
uh,
you know,
was bashed in the head with a baseball bat.
Let's go to that house.
I go to those places,
the way other people go to Disneyland.
I know.
Is that a real place?
Like you went to the,
uh,
Hogan's Heroes Guy's house?
I haven't been to his house.
It wasn't a house by the rain.
First of all.
Let's get our facts straight.
Sorry.
Okay.
It's apartment.
It was Bob crane who played Hogan heroes at the time was doing regional theater
and he was staying in sort of the equivalent of kind of a hotel,
but kind of a weekly apartment sort of place.
I apologize.
Yeah,
that's all right.
And uh,
yeah,
he was a legend in his room,
most likely.
And I'm risking a lawsuit here by his best friend at the time,
uh,
who escaped prosecution.
Uh,
what's not talk about that anymore.
I haven't been there.
I haven't made the pilgrimage,
uh,
to go to Arizona and see that,
that hotel that's on my list though.
I'll get there.
I want to make that a family pilgrimage.
I'm like,
God,
the whole family to go.
I don't know if you want to talk about this.
When I first started working for you,
I remember I had to drive you home and we drove by the house where Sharon Tate
was murdered and you can't drive past that house.
You've got to drive all the way up.
That's what I feel is right.
No,
no.
Well now you know.
You just try to throw it misinformation.
I might be.
I'll wait.
That's your job.
I think you're thinking of the murder house,
the murder house,
Polanski places.
Plasty places,
I guess actually,
yeah,
at the top of a,
I think it's LC yellow.
It is.
He'll see yellow.
Sorry,
just to kind of thing I had in my head.
It's ELC yellow.
That's all right.
Oh,
how's that Bagel?
I just love correcting you.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well you showed me.
I said l instead of ill,
you made a big old while.
Rome burned.
He just needed to go on a conference call.
All right.
We're going to get some stuff straight here.
Poorly.
Gourley you've got to get it together.
You're going to interject things like the house where Bob Crane was killed,
which is incorrect.
Or if you're going to interject,
uh,
that,
oh yeah,
the Sharon Tate Polanski House that's in,
in Los filets incorrect.
I mean,
that's going to be a stick in the spoke of the wheel.
That is the bicycle that is this podcast.
The other murders were in Litchfield is gotta be you're thinking you're about
Labianca.
Yeah.
And I appreciate the fact checking.
I do.
I think,
and I born,
I didn't want to have a harsh tone.
I'm tough on you because I see great potential.
Thank you.
That means a lot.
I appreciate it.
I really do think that one day,
uh,
I think you're going to go on to great things and that's why Burgess Meredith
was tough.
Uh,
you know the coat to the,
what's his name?
Uh,
Mickey.
Thank you.
See Mickey.
Yeah,
the trainer was tough on rock.
I got that right.
Yeah,
no.
Oh,
he's Mickey.
Wait,
I'm still alone.
I'm sorry.
You're talking about,
you're tough on him.
He's still on.
He's rocky.
Oh No.
This is a bad allergy then he can't be rocky.
No,
I you just want to be rocked.
Allergy.
A bad allergy.
Did I say,
I think you did.
They think you think I said lately.
I've said lately I'm worried that I have something wrong with my brain because
I,
I'm very good at saying the right word and lately the right word isn't coming
out.
This podcast may turn out to be a chronicle of my decline.
Well,
it seems like we're all in some way each other's Mickey and Stallone and Miyagi
and Daniel and it's going to be interesting to see where this goes.
I refuse to accept that.
Really?
Yes.
I will not be Mickey to your Stallone.
I am Stallone.
Do you think I'm like training and mentoring you?
I mean,
I'll take it,
but it seems like you don't know where that puts you.
I don't care.
I'm that I'm his drunk buddy.
Oh,
you know who you are.
Yes.
You're Burt young.
Very young.
You're young.
You're a Talia Shire.
His brother.
That's right.
You're an alcoholic.
That feels right and a bully and you work in a meat packing plant that feels bad
and I am still alone,
sculpted it Donnis one of the biggest stars of the seventies eighties nineties
and then think,
I don't know what he's doing now.
Do you need to go to a hospital?
I would like to go to a hospital.
Right.
Let's go.
I want a good television.
Oh,
good.
Flat screen and I want pudding and I want to stay there for two weeks and I want
it to be a good bed.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Let's take you to the hospital.
Conan O'brien needs a friend with SONA,
Sonoma obsessing and Conan O'brien as himself,
produced by me,
Matt Gorley,
executive produced by Adam Sachs and Jeff Ross at Team Coco and Collin Anderson
and Chris Ben.
And at your special thanks to Jack White and the white stripes for the theme
song,
incidental music by Jimmy Vivino.
You can rate and review this show on apple podcasts and you might find your
review featured on a future episode.
Got a question for Conan called the team coco hotline at (323) 451-2821 and
leave a message it to could be featured on a future episode.
And if you haven't already,
please subscribe to Conan O'brian needs a friend on apple podcasts,
stitcher,
or wherever fine podcasts are down.
This has pith cocoa production in association with Wolf Dan Gilbert Godfrey's.
Amazing colossal podcast.
Hi,
I'm Alan Alda and I'm a guest on Gilbert Godfried.
Amazing colossal podcast.
You got to listen to this.
They made me laugh and left like this.
You were not prepared for what a big star you would come after that.
How's that great story about how your face was more recognized to those students
than Lincoln's?
Isn't that weird?
Bizarre and Lincoln [inaudible] dig tried in my face and Lincoln's face and they
showed it to school children at and during those years,
they recognize me more easily than Lincoln.
And that's hard to believe because he had his own penny.
Join Gilbert Frank and their guests,
Alan Alda this Monday,
wherever you listen to podcasts.